I'm Shannon and I'm a Scoutmaster and a Dem Leader with Trooper 1 and Pac-66 in Virginia Beach, Virginia.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me,
And now it's your Scoutmaster.
Here's something that came across recently from listener and reader Paul Teal:
Everything we do is for the Scouts, but we don't do everything for the Scouts.
I like that. Thank you, Paul. Everything we do is for the Scouts, but we don't do everything for the Scouts.
Couldn't have said it better.
Hey, this is podcast number 237..
Finally,
Yes, 237..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast. This is indeed Clark Green and I've been away for a bit.
Let me take a few minutes and just explain what's been going on.
If you have been a longtime listener, follower, reader of the blog, you will know that my father passed away early in September.
So I've taken an extended leave of absence from the podcast and the blog to spend time with my family and to manage the many issues involved.
Dad passed away peacefully at the age of 91, surrounded by the ones that he loved.
We recently laid him to rest in Arlington National Cemetery with the honors do of veteran of the Second World War.
There's a story to be told of his service.
It's something that I'm going to be working on for the next several months and I hope to share with you.
I want to thank the many listeners and readers who sent messages of condolence and support and inquiring after my own state of mind and whether or not I was okay,
And you know what. I'm fine.
As you can imagine, it's been a difficult and trying time for everyone, but your messages of condolence and support have been very, very meaningful.
So I really want to say that I appreciate that,
And now we're ready to get back with the Scoutmaster blog and the podcast and get things rolling again.
Boy, do I have a big backlog of email, questions and other messages that I'll be sharing in the next several podcasts.
Let's take a look at what I've got on the list for this week.
Uche Akuba is skipper of Sea Scout Ship 272 in New York
And he wrote to say: your podcasts are invaluable and change my outlook as a scouter.
I'm actually less stressed and have so much more fun with the Scouts.
Well, I'm glad that we've been able to help you, Uche,
And I appreciate your message.
Parker Lewisin left a nice review of the Kindle edition,
That's, the electronic book edition of So Far, So Good- A New Scoutmaster Story.
He said it's excellent reading material for seasoned leaders and new leaders.
Clark made every effort to cover situations that any leader would encounter as they attempt to create a boy-led troop.
Well, thank you, Parker. I appreciate that.
Also heard from Richard Exnesios, who's with Troop 56 in New Orleans, Louisiana.
He says thanks so much for this resource. We're a relatively new troop and we need all the information we can get.
There seems to be too much information out there to sort through and get a definitive answer.
Well, Richard, I'm glad we can help. I know it could be a bit of a thicket
trying to figure out exactly where the answers are and which answers are actually useful,
And I do my best to try and sort things out and share them with you here on the podcast and on the blog.
Hey, the t-shirts are still selling. How about that?
The Stuff Scouters say t-shirts available over on Amazon.
I'll have a link to it in the podcast notes
And there were a number of comments left over the past several weeks.
The shirts: I hit with all my scouter friends.
I work at a scout camp and I get a lot of FaceTime with others.
I love it. Other scout masters are jealous.
Well, you know. take a look at that, See if it interests you.
Two hundred and some phrases that scouters say over and over and over again.
So over the past several weeks we haven't been doing too many chat sessions.
I had a chance to get a couple out.
I'm going to try and get back on a regular schedule of that.
This is the way that it works.
I'll be at ScoutMasterCGcom most Tuesday and Wednesday mornings with a live chat.
If you keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed,
I'll announce when I'm going to be there for a live chat.
Check in, sign on, where we talk about a broad spectrum of issues,
Everything from the weather to important things that you might want to know as a scouter.
And in addition to the many scouters who are frequent fliers
and sign on to the chat regularly,
we recently heard from Fred Rossmark in Severna Park, Maryland,
who's a former den leader in CubMaster and looking for an official troop role.
Christian Kowski is a Weeblos den leader in Crystal Lake Illinois
with PAC and Troop 168..
Dominic Galoro checked in.
He's an assistant scout master in Marion Iowa.
Courtney Lane Clapper is a troop committee secretary
and the wife of an assistant scout master in Southwest Florida.
All those folks have checked in on the chat.
Once again, keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed.
I'll make sure to announce when I'm going to be on the live chat over at ScoutMasterCGcom.
I want to take a moment to mention if you're a regular reader and listener-
even though for the past several weeks it's been a little bit difficult to be a regular reader and listener-
and the resources we've created have helped you.
You can return the favor and support this work financially
by making a one-time payment and becoming a ScoutMasterCGcom backer,
or make kind of a subscription payment via a service called Patreon
by pledging $5 or more a month,
And there are special premiums available to anyone who becomes a patron or a backer.
Look for the backer and patron links in the podcast notes
or go to ScoutMasterCGcom right there at the top right hand side of the page.
You can click the support link and the be a patron link to check out on the options for those-
And I want to take a moment to personally think:
wow, this is a big list-
Kevin Byrne, Jeff Sabuda, Steve Jackson, Ryan Smith, Lisa Williams,
John Burnside, Paul Prusinski, Ted Miller, Walter Tomlinson,
Morgan McDermott, Tom Perry, Robert Acker and Chris Jordan
who have become backers since our last podcast,
And I want to also thank Steve Jackson and Bill Chapman,
who have become patrons since our last podcast.
Take a little time this week, figure out which option works for you
and I'll be sure to thank you personally on next week's podcast.
The remainder of this podcast is going to be taken up by answering an email question
that came across the transom here within the past several weeks.
that, I think, raises some issues that are always worth talking about.
So let's get started, shall we?
When I get all steamed up, then I shout: tip me over and pull me out,
Tip me over and pull me out,
Tip me over and pull me out.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is, folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Well, for very obvious reasons, I'm not going to share the name
or the location of the person that asked this question via email,
but let's just dive in.
They wrote to say: my family loves scouting,
My son loves scouting, but we're having difficulties with our troop.
One of our scouts got in trouble last year at school.
He was punished at school, punished at home,
and after the scouters of our troop found out about this incident.
they placed him on probation for months.
My star scout son was turned down six times for a life service project.
The scout master told him he was too young
and too immature to be an Eagle Scout.
The troop adopted a new system for approving star or life service projects
that requires filling out part of the Eagle paperwork
and unanimous approval of the troop committee.
My husband and assistant scout master tried to point out
that this was outside BSA policy,
but he was told that it has been voted as a new troop policy.
My question is: are these policies legitimate?
Can a troop place scouts on probation for things
that didn't even happen in scouts?
Can a scout master prevent scouts from advancing because of their age?
These are common questions, unfortunately,
that I've addressed a number of times
and I want to take a little time to kind of delve into them in this podcast.
The first question is:
can a troop place scouts on probation
for things that didn't even happen in scouts,
Distressingly? the answer is yes.
A troop can probably adopt a policy to do that,
but to my mind it is inadvisable either to adopt the policy
or to place scouts on probation.
The second question:
can a scout master prevent scouts from advancing because of their age?
That's an easy answer: No,
Although distressingly, a lot of scout masters seem to think
that it's their job to judge the maturity of a scout
and to put the brakes on if they feel these immature for some reason.
The third question is the most important one, probably,
and it's not directly expressed in this email:
How does a family deal with these kinds of things happening in a troop?
And when you get down to practicalities,
a wrong-headed scouter can do all kinds of silly, stupid things
that hold scouts back and you won't change their mind.
You won't change the mind of the other adults involved.
I've worked with literally hundreds of troops and thousands of adult volunteers
and once people are entrenched in this kind of mindset
where they're going to make policies and they're going to make judgments
about scout's maturity and they're going to hold a hard line about things,
you're not going to get anywhere with them,
And the advice that I've given people many, many times
is to get out of that situation and find another troop.
Most places there's another troop out there
that hues a little closer to the line
and kind of gets what scouting is all about.
I hear about situations like this from time to time,
and if you find yourself in this kind of situation,
the one thing that you should first understand is you're not alone,
And the second thing is that this is not the fault of the scouts involved.
It's the adults who are simply mistaken about their role in scouting.
The best bet if you find yourself in that kind of situation
is walking away from the mess and not looking back,
not having any arguments or making any parting shots.
you just pack up and leave.
Visit a couple of other troops, talk to the scout masters,
get your son to talk to the scout master
and you'll find one who gets the program.
So listen carefully to this, okay,
Leave these folks who are causing you problems behind.
No arguments, no parting shots, just leave.
The only thing that matters in this situation
is the interest of the scouts involved,
and that's the only thing that matters 100% of the time.
In a month or two, this whole thing will be in your rear view mirror,
Your son will be enjoying scouts and you can move on.
That is my typical advice for that third unspoken question.
Let's go back and examine the first two questions a little closer.
Question number one was:
can a troop place scouts on probation for things that didn't even happen in scouts,
And I've had that question a couple of times in the past several weeks
from different people.
And just for clarity, troops are permitted
to implement appropriate disciplinary rules and corresponding penalties
and it's mentioned in the literature.
But my convention is that this is a very bad idea
because we deal with every scout
and every situation individually,
based on that scout's understanding of the scout oath and the scout law.
If there's a discipline problem with a scout in a troop
and it needs correction, the scout is referred to as parents
and they can return him to active participation
when they're ready to assure the troop that the issue is resolved.
Scouts are not to discipline or punish children.
That's up to their parents
And that's the way I've learned how to do things
and what I recommend to others.
It's not necessarily a matter of official policy or procedure
And you should always check my advice against the resources out there.
But let me expand upon this whole idea for a moment.
I don't think a scouter is necessarily a bad person
or is totally misinformed
If they decide they're going to have disciplinary rules
and penalties and things like that in their troop.
I just think they don't understand their role very well,
And let me explain why.
Our children spend the majority of their lives
in activities and situations
where rules are made and penalties are defined,
and that is what we've come to expect.
School districts and sports teams and community organizations
who work with young people often find themselves at an impasse
where they have to define some rules
and they have to define penalties for breaking those rules.
Sounds perfectly reasonable,
And you know what
It is in some situations.
But I've never seen any positive effect
of this sort of thing in a scout troop,
because a scout troop is a different kind of a situation.
It's not school, it's not a sports team,
it's not a typical activity
that a young person will involve themselves in.
Scout troops may have some similarity with those things,
but they are different because of the aims
they are trying to achieve.
The aim we're trying to achieve as scouters
is to develop character in young people
using the scout oath and law.
We really don't have any other aims.
There are some ancillary benefits that come out of that,
but that is the main aim.
That's what we're all about.
You can't develop the character
of an entire group of people.
You can only do it one individual at a time.
And if you impose a bunch of rules and penalties
for a group. what you've done
is you've tied your hands about being able to deal
with individual situations.
So let me explain my experience
with a couple of situations
that hopefully shed some light
on what I'm trying to say.
Many years ago one of my scouts
came to the attention of the authorities
because he had threatened
another young person with a pocket knife.
In that case I did not have a whole lot of choice
but to talk to his parents and to say
that until that incident
was resolved with the authorities,
I couldn't really permit him
to participate actively with the troop
and that, whether or not there were
a lot of mitigating circumstances involved,
the incident rose to the level
of an immediate concern
for other people's safety
and I had very little choice in the matter.
I explained that I was not placing the scout
on any kind of a probation
or trying to punish him
in any way,
but that the only thing
that would satisfy the concerns
over the safety of the other scouts
was to tell his family
that he could not actively participate
until these matters were resolved.
Over the course of 30 years
I've had scouts who've done all kinds
of things outside of scouting
that were inconsistent
with the scout oath and law.
These things have happened at school
or in the broader community.
They've come to the attention of
either the school or the scout's parents
or the scout's friends.
I've heard about them.
None of these things would raise
their fellow scouts
if they continued to participate in scouts,
but they did raise a concern
as to how well they understood
the scout oath and law
and whether or not they were going to be able
to follow the scout oath and law.
If I become aware of one of these situations,
I'm going to sit down
with that individual scout
and we're going to discuss the situation
in the light of the scout oath and law.
I can tell you that
in those discussions,
if you want to say to a scout,
your understanding of the scout oath and law
is so imperfect
or so radically
outside of the norm
that you cannot be permitted
to be around other scouts,
Quite to the contrary,
what I find is that young people
are usually very, very sensitive
to these issues
and these ideals
and that if you discuss it with them
in the right manner,
you ask them to explain
their behavior in the light
of the scout oath and law,
They get it right nearly every single time
They understand
the difference between their behavior
and the ideals
that we encourage them
to strive towards.
Now it's not uncommon that a scout
in this kind of situation will be dealing
with some kind of penalty
in another area of his life.
He might be suspended from school,
He might be discharged at home,
He may have, as a result of his actions,
had a fallout with his friends.
But I return to the idea
that our aim
is to help scouts develop character,
and the tools of developing character
are the scout oath and law.
and when you sit down and you discuss
the ideals
of the oath and law with scouts,
rather than your judgment
about their actions
or their maturity
or their actions,
that you and the scout
will discover a way to resolve
the issue.
If the only tools in your toolbox
to resolve this kind of issue
are a set of rules
and policies that the troop committee
decided they needed to vote on
and put on pieces of paper
that also involve penalties,
you're not going to be able to resolve
the issue with the scout.
You're not going to have the opportunity
or the values of the scout oath and law
within the scout. You're only going to be able
to issue a judgment and a punishment.
So consider, before
trying to set out a list of rules
with associated penalties,
consider how much you are
limiting yourself in your work
as a scouter. Now the second question
here: can
a scout master prevent scouts
from advancing because of their age?
The short and long answers
are both yes and no.
If you go through the Guide to Advancement,
you will not find
a statement specifically
prohibiting this idea,
because the Guide to Advancement
can't deal with every
stupid idea
that somebody may have about
who gets to advance. when
The Guide to Advancement isn't cursing the darkness,
it's lighting a candle. okay,
And if you go and you read the Guide to Advancement
advising us on how to
judge the suitability of a scout
for a given award, you won't see
any ages mentioned,
other than the fact that
there's a minimum age for
becoming a scout and a maximum age
for staying a scout. To expand on that
question, I can understand
why a scouter would look at
a younger scout challenging
one of the higher ranks-
Star, Life or Eagle- and be concerned
about the scout's relative
maturity. But maturity
is not mentioned
explicitly in any requirement
for any of those ranks.
Some of the requirements may indeed
describe the aspects
of a person's character that would indicate
maturity, but there's no exact
measure of maturity mentioned anywhere
in those requirements. And one rabbit
hole that we can jump down for
just a moment is the
whole discussion that comes up
when there's a 13 or 14 year old
Eagle scout, and everybody
tears out their hair
and wrens their garments over the fact
that this is an impossible thing.
that should never happen, and
I will get out of the rabbit hole
by saying this: there is only
one way to become
an Eagle scout, And that is
to fulfill the requirements
and pass a duly
constituted border review.
That's it. There's no other
way to become an Eagle scout. Now you
can argue until the cows come
home about exactly what an Eagle
scout is and how it should be
and everything like that. The most
satisfactory answer I have to those
arguments is that becoming
an Eagle scout is certainly achieving
a rank by completing
requirements, but it is only
the beginning of a process
that carries on throughout
one's life, And if we've done
our job as scouters, we
understand our job as scouters
as achieving the aim of
developing character. through the scout
law, All of our scouts,
no matter what rank they achieve,
no matter how many advancement
awards they have on their shirts
when they leave us have
tools to become kind,
compassionate, contributing citizens,
strong, inspiring
leaders and all around
good folks for the rest
of their lives. That's what's really
important, isn't it? So that's
a very long answer
to a relatively
simple, multi-question
email,
But I think these things are
so important that we need to go back.
we need to look at them on occasion. If you have a
question for me and you'd like to get
in touch, it's very simple to do
and I'm going to tell you how to make that
happen in just a moment.
Well, thanks for
listening to this
327th
edition of the
Scoutmaster
Podcast. Here's how to keep in touch.
You'll find lots and lots
of articles and 300 plus
editions of the podcast at
scoutmastercgcom,
where you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog and the podcast.
Thanks for listening to this 327th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
We are subscribed to receive updates to the
blog and the podcast by email.
We are in the vast
panorama of social media outlets.
There's over 14,000 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
where you're much more than
just another face in the crowd.
We have a chorus of tweeters on Twitter
that type truly tremendous, thoughtful tweets.
We pin Pultritudinous
pictures and proffer them publicly
with a parcel of prolific pinners on Pinterest.
You can watch us at ScoutmasterCG
on YouTube. but if you can't face
Facebook and Twitter makes you better. you
know interest in Pinterest and you don't
put the? U in YouTube, well, that's
alright. You just zoom in to the late
1990s and fire
off an email. I'm always
available at Clark, at
scoutmastercgcom,
at C-L-A-R-K-E,
at
scoutmastercgcom.
Now, if all else fails,
write your message on a piece of paper,
seal it up in a bottle and bury it
in any campfire circle.
I'll be sure to get it, because I have agents
everywhere, trust me. By now, it should
be abundantly clear that the Scoutmaster
blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of anyone other than
myself. I'm not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America or any
scouting organization for that matter.
It's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scouts and have
a little bit of fun along the way. and
thinking of fun. here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck
to you and good camping.
Well, I thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.